- This video is brought
to you by Surfshark VPN.
What's up cowboys and cowgirls?
Michael here and today,
I wanna talk about our
favorite comedic genius,
turned horror a tour, Jordan Peele.
His new movie, 'Nope" just hit theaters.
And while we're gonna
save a full breakdown
for its digital release,
we're too stoked to wait to tackle
one of the big ideas Peele
explorers in the film,
"Spectacle," and we're
not projecting here.
Peele himself said that the movie
is about our addiction to spectacle
and characters in the movie
repeat the word enough
just to remind us.
"Nope" explores the ways in which
we're all obsessed with spectacles
and how we all secretly hope
at least, just a little bit
to witness some outrageous moment
that compels us to pull out our iPhones,
hit record and hopefully find fame
even if doing so is super dangerous.
So let's saddle up and
see how a sci-fi tinged
horror Western can help us
understand our modern condition
in this mostly spoiler free
wise crack quick take on "Nope."
Is everything spectacle now?
But before we really get into it,
I wanna tell you about this
video sponsor, Surfshark VPN.
Surfshark VPN keeps your data secure
everywhere you go on the internet,
thanks to their secure protocols
and uncrackable encryption.
Now, one of my favorite
things about Surfshark VPN
is that it keeps my
location totally private
which is a huge help
when it comes to things
like buying plane tickets
which is important 'cause they're
really expensive right now.
Simply connect your secure Surfshark VPN
to other VPNs around the world
and then you can easily
track down the best deals.
And speaking of the rest of the world,
these connections also let
you watch all the movies
and TV you like especially content
that hasn't been released
in your country yet.
Plus all your favorite
devices are included
in a single subscription,
including your laptop,
Android, Amazon Firestick,
PlayStation and more
and you can still use
your favorite apps too
like Chrome and Firefox.
Get started by clicking
the link in the description
and using the promo code, wisecrack.
When you do, you can get Surfshark VPN
for 83% off plus three
extra months for free.
Go to Surfshark.deals/wisecrack
or hit the link in the description.
Protect yourself online and
download Surfshark VPN today.
And now back to the show.
"Nope," is about a brother
OJ and sister Emerald
whose family farm trains horses
for Hollywood productions.
Their great, great great grandfather
was the unknown black jockey featured
in the first ever moving image
created by Eadweard Muybridge.
Now, while the moving image is real,
Peele made up the anonymous
black jockey's identity for the film.
So on camera spectacle
clearly runs in the family.
After their father mysteriously dies,
OJ notices something strange in the sky.
You're probably not
stunned that what he sees
looks like an alien spacecraft.
But instead of wisely
choosing to get the out
and never look back like I would,
they decide to try and
capture the site on camera
so they can get there
because why worry about
potentially being zapped
or probed to death by aliens
so long as you go viral.
And this feels like the first indication
that Peele wants us to reflect
on our own societal
fascination with spectacle
whether we're creating it, filming it
or simply consuming the
potentially horrible
and shocking sites from a tiny screen
as we sit on the toilet,
none of us seem to be immune.
Okay, so in a surprise
twist that would shock
even the most seasoned
wise crack horror fan.
We're gonna explore this idea
with the help of a French philosopher.
I bet you didn't see that one coming,
but seriously we can't
help it that the French
are good at using philosophy to analyze
the decline of human culture.
And one of these folks Guy Debord
wrote a book in 1967 called,"
the Society of the Spectacle"
which opens with the line,
"in societies or modern
conditions of production prevail,
all of life presents itself
as an immense accumulation of spectacles."
For Debord, the modern
spectacle has turned a society
primarily based on
relations between humans
into one that prioritizes
relations between commodities
i.e, economic relations matter
more than human beings.
And we see a bit of this in an early scene
where OJ is treated like,
by some commercial director
and his real life horse
is ultimately replaced by a CGI stand-in.
According to de bore's definition,
spectacle is perceived in
three ways all at once,
as all of society, as part of society
and as instrument of unification.
For him, as spectacle underlies
all social perspectives
and all consciousness,
as he explains, "due to the very fact
that this sector is separate,
it is the common ground
of the deceased gaze
and of false consciousness
and the unification it achieves is nothing
but in all official language
of generalized separation"
I.e by keeping us all focused
on various spectacles,
society turns us into zombies
with deceased gazes, isolated from others
and from our own humanity.
Basically living in the spectacle,
our constant impulse to talk about
if we've seen the new thing
or heard about what happened
or read the crazy tweets
or saw that weird guy's TikTok
or the politicians leaked nudes
becomes what society is for most of us.
And in a world where this
is what is most real,
why wouldn't a brother and
sister in need of cash,
see capturing an alien ship on camera
as a way to really make
their lives matter?
When Debord talks about
the unification achieved
by the spectacle being
an official language of
generalized separation,
he's getting at the way in which
our gaze being caught in the spectacle,
alienates us from each other.
When our heads are all
looking down at our phones,
we're not relating to anyone else.
And we're definitely not
considering the humanity
of those on our screens
and ultimately that dehumanizes all of us.
And in "Nope," when the ex child star Jupe
post the show at his Western theme park,
we see everyone gazing up at the spectacle
with this deceased gaze.
The message seemingly being,
show me something shocking
or else I'm not interested.
And of course, here it's being
done for the sake of profit.
For Debord, the alienation
of the spectator
to the profit of the contemplated object
is expressed in the following way,
the more he contemplates,
the less he lives,
the more he accepts recognizing himself
and the dominant images of need,
the less he understands his own existence
and his own desires.
I.e, the more we get
caught up in the images
and spectacles that are sold to us,
the more we lose ourselves in the process.
And in "Nope," we see what happens
when individuals get so
caught up in being spectators
that they risk losing
themselves in the spectacle.
Now, while we might not
be risking our lives
to get shots of extra terrestrials,
we might think of the spectacle
of the January 6th
attack on the US Capital.
Most of us were glued
to our TVs or phones,
transfixed by the chaos.
And if we're honest, there is something
sickly compelling about it that
we couldn't look away from.
This isn't an individual
moral failure either.
A lifetime of constantly
consuming spectacle
makes everything seem unreal
as the desire to be shocked,
eclipses are basic humanity.
And of course, when you look
at footage from that day,
it's no coincidence that so many people
have their phones out recording
and streaming the events
because if a right wing
political attack happens
and you don't record it,
did it even really happen?
And at an even darker level,
there is a disturbing
trend of mass shooters
who are literally streaming
their horrific acts
as if they were just gamers
searching for subscribes
and likes with their kills.
In "Nope," Peele seems to be saying
that the obsession with spectacle
is something that affects all of us
and not in positive ways.
And as we sit in the theater
transfixed by the screen,
we can't help but think about
all the movies we consumed
that are themselves a little more
than empty spectacles of capital.
As we watch famous actors
phoning in their performances
against CGI backgrounds
doing little more than
making empty references
and dropping Easter
eggs that are more about
consumer desire than they are
about engaging narratives
and, you know, blowing up.
They're always blowing up.
For Devord, the spectacle presents itself
as something enormously positive
and disputable and inaccessible.
It says nothing more than
that which appears is good,
that which is good appears.
This attitude which it
demands in principle
is passive acceptance
which in fact it already obtained
by its manner of appearing without reply,
by its monopoly of appearance.
So whether it's our continued consumption
of corporately repackaged IP
being served to us across various screens,
or people who seem absolutely
unable to do anything
other than put themselves in harm's way
to experience the pure spectacle
of chasing down alien life.
A society built on spectacle
builds power over us
when we accept the idea
that whatever appears
is good and worth watching,
or as Peele puts it,
the film also deals with the
toxic nature of attention
and the insidious of our
human addiction is spectacle.
But what do you guys think?
There's no persuasively critique
our societal obsession with spectacle,
or as Jordan Peele himself,
just cashing in on our love
of a good old fashioned alien blockbuster.
Let us know what you think in the comments
and as always thanks to our
patrons for your support
and be sure to check out
our new Patron features.
Also, if you haven't checked it out yet,
check out our new stream, wisecrack live,
it happens right here every
Thursday at 11:00 AM Pacific.
If you enjoyed our little
spectacle about spectacles,
be sure to like this video,
subscribe and ring that bell
and as always thanks for watching, later.
(upbeat music)